[Music]
Robert Spencer here for jihad watch a
program of the David Horowitz Freedom
Center and for the center of for
Security Policy the new top dog of
Britain's counter-terror Police has
asked Britain's to become
counterterrorism citizens by reporting
suspicious activity given the way
Britain treats foes of jihad terror
however it's unlikely that he means it
Metropolitan Police Assistant
Commissioner Neil Basu did his best
however to give the opposite impression
he said people are nervous about police
overreacting or about wasting our time
but it's never a waste of our time the
independent reported that people are
being asked to look out for suspicious
behavior including possessing weapons
chemicals fertilizers or gas cylinders
for no obvious reason carrying out
surveillance having unusual items
delivered expressing extremist ideas or
searching for terrorist material online
the independent also articulated why
basses call rings hollow it said critics
argued that the call for public help was
paving the way to the worst kind of
profiling vigilantism and paranoia amid
ongoing controversy around the
government's counter extremism prevent
program bhasu however stood his ground
he insisted that police were not going
to overreact to a single piece of
intelligence and reiterated the point is
you don't have to make that judgment you
just have to feel nervous and if you
feel nervous you shouldn't sit on it you
should report it
some people say isn't that a bit obvious
or it's normal behavior and that's
absolutely true but you've got to take
that with people's judgement I think
people have good instincts about what
feels odd in their workplace in their
community and even in their family and
just so that no one would think that
basu was asking people to be suspicious
of Muslims in particular he engaged in
some fanciful moral equivalence claiming
that in the last year the UK had seen 10
foiled Islamist plots and four planned
attacks by the extreme right involving
similar methods Basu added lone actors
on the extreme right are copycatting
some of the methodology that has been
used by Islamist jihadists
the world the independent claimed that
the threat from both Islamists and the
extreme right has been increasing as
analysts document both groups feeding
off each other
in a process known as reciprocal
rattling radicalization passes words and
the independence coverage of them
demonstrate that the British government
is going all-in with its contention that
far-right extremists are an equivalent
threat to Islamic Jihad ease however
this equivalence is exposed as mere
propaganda when one recalls that the
most prominent people that the British
government has said are far-right
extremists include Tommy Robinson the
recently banned Martin Sellner Brittany
Pettibone and Lauren's southern as well
as Pamela Geller and me yet none of us
that I have just named have ever called
for or condoned any vigilantism or
violence our only crime is opposing
jihad terror and Sharia oppression
Theresa May in late 2016 likened Pamela
Geller and me to Abu Hamza and Abu
Qatada and in doing so showed the
bankruptcy of this equivalence Abu Hamza
repeatedly preached violence against
infidels and is currently in prison for
aiding an attempt to set up an al Qaeda
training camp in Oregon Abu Qatada
likewise was involved in the planning of
jihad terror plots to liken us when we
have never been involved in or approved
of any violence or illegal activity was
obscenely libelous when basu claimed
that there were ten foiled Islamist
plots and four planned attacks by the
extreme right involving similar methods
he didn't offer any details and without
them it's extremely hard to believe that
there really were four attempted terror
attacks by the so-called extreme right
besides having no terror leaders the
extreme right is not part of a global
movement that has declared war on
Britain in other countries it is not
boasted about how it will soon conquer
and subjugate Britain it has no ideology
or political system that it is
determined to put into place primarily
the British government has demonized as
extreme right those who don't want to
see their country destroyed by further
jihad massacres and ongoing Islamization
and so now neo Basu wants people to
report suspicious activity great but now
the British government is imprisoning
and persecuting people for so-called
Islamic obeah so if someone sees a jihad
Massacre being plotted the witness must
be very careful when alerting British
authorities for that suspicion itself
could be seen as Islamophobic especially
if the witness is non-muslim in today's
Britain foes of jihad terror who sees
something better say nothing if they
want to keep from getting arrested
themselves I'm Robert Spencer
[Music]